[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm QB HD here and
it's only October but I would say it's
been a pretty quiet year so far for LG
but this is for sure
their most underrated phone out right
now this is the LG v20 I don't know if
you remember it but back when Android
7.0 was first announced it was this
phone sitting down at the bottom of that
website advertising that it would be the
first one out the box with Android 7.0
nougat installed not a nexus not a pixel
phone but this one and it still is it's
a thing now so the height has died down
a little bit and it's been a little bit
quieter but the v20 is a really good
phone from LG so these are the five best
things about it number five is the deck
so this phone has a headphone jack which
we won't be able to take for granted
much longer but the deck behind it is
not just your normal typical digital to
analog converter so the v20 is rocking a
32-bit hi-fi quad DAC for significantly
improved headphone and speaker audio
performance now the speakers themselves
I wouldn't say are extraordinary I mean
one of them is front-facing and they do
get pretty good and loud so if that's
something you care about that's a good
sign but where you'll really hear the
difference is with headphones you might
not necessarily notice the difference in
audio quality right off the bat even
with the great headphones that come with
it but with the quad DAC what it will do
is drive higher impedance headphones so
if you have the higher-end headphones
that require much more power even too
much power to get much sound out of
previous phones this one is up to the
task you will be able to drive much
higher impedance headphones with a quad
DAC in the V 20 so that is a nice bonus
if you used to try to drive high-end
headphones with a smart phone before you
needed to buy like a mobile DAC external
to the phone so you'd carry around extra
things and you have to remember to take
it with you you'd have to do any of that
with the V 20 this one will handle all
so number four is the hardware and just
the overall build quality and fit and
finish of the V 20 it is a lot better
than the g5 from earlier this year not
that that was a very high bar to clear
but still this is a seriously well-built
phone this time around it's a unibody
aluminum phone from top to bottom and it
actually is really it feels really light
like it feels like it should be heavier
for the size of the phone but it's
really balanced across that size in the
and the forehead is not too big the chin
is not too big you got a pretty good use
of space fitting a 5.7 inch quad-hd
display onto the front of this body size
and it has a ton of bonuses it's
military-grade shock resistant against
drops it has a fingerprint reader on the
back that's really quick and also
doubles as your power button and a
sleep/wake switch it has a 3,200
milliamp hour removable battery and the
weight removes in this version is the
button on the side that pops the back
off and it is way cleaner than the g5s
method which would just force shut down
the phone immediately so you can open
the back and this way lets you take off
the back without shutting down the phone
which you might want to do because
there's also expandable storage a micro
SD card slot so those last two things
right there the removable battery and
expandable storage on a high-end
smartphone by themselves kind of make it
a rare breed so number three is the
secondary display this is an LG thing
for sure they did it in the v10 and I'm
happy they're keeping it going with the
V 20 so it's the secondary display right
up in the top of the phone above the
main display this second screen is like
a dock for permanent shortcuts to things
you might do often so toggles for some
settings etc some quick Wi-Fi toggle a
quick flash light toggle obviously it's
even faster than dragging down the
notification shade and then finding what
you want selecting it because you can
leave it there all the time forever just
one click I do wish two things though
one I wish I had more control over what
exactly shows up on this top screen if I
had a my way I would have just one top
screen permanently no swiping at all and
then I would just have this as a mixture
of some apps and some shortcuts so I
would have some of my favorite apps to
launch all the time and some of my
favorite click settings toggles I could
have my favorite Twitter app out of
Phoenix up here I'd probably have a
camera app shortcut but I'd also have
like a Wi-Fi toggle a Bluetooth pair
button probably a flashlight but as of
right now it's just whatever LG seized
it and the other thing is I'm still not
sure about the position of the screen on
the top of the phone especially for
people with smaller hands than me this
is not easy to reach and if you're
trying to make it a shortcut thing you
want to make it as accessible as
possible so I don't know maybe put it on
the bottom of the phone maybe try
another location other than up at the
top above everything which is kind of a
stretch for most people but that's just
me right so the number two best feature
in vivid xx is
these dual cameras on the back so this
is also a very LG thing they've been
doing it before so no the iPhone is not
the first one to do dual cameras in fact
this one's not the first one LG did in
previous phones with their g5 they did
it in the v10 and I've done an entire
video explaining all of the way dual
cameras work and smartphones what they
do why they're useful so I'll leave that
video linked a little like button if you
want to check it out for those
unfamiliar the v20 is rocking 116
megapixel regular field of view camera
and one 8 megapixel 135 degrees super
wide angle camera so yeah every phone
with dual camera seems to have a
different way of utilizing them and this
LG way is pretty much purely for
recreation sometimes for utility if
you're really close to a subject and you
want to get zoomed out wide but the
imagery from the second camera doesn't
really get used to supplement the image
from the first camera or vice versa
they're totally independent cameras
which you can switch between to get a
different look and that super wide angle
camera does look really cool it's kind
of like that GoPro look so the cameras
look really fun plus there's a bunch of
other bonuses like having really good
optical image stabilization their study
shot 2.0 for video and you have all your
manual modes for photos and videos you
have your raw photo capability you have
your improved microphone for better
sensitivity for recording audio and like
loud environments so in general this is
shaping up to be a pretty great Android
smartphone camera and then last but not
least the number one best feature of the
LG v 20 is the software this is like we
mentioned earlier the first phone
running out the box Android 7.0 nougat
which is an interesting choice because
this one's already skin so as Android
7.0 nougat with the LG UI on top of it
we're going to see more Android 7.0
unscanned on some phones coming up very
soon but until then we still get to see
plenty of new gets features in action so
there's Google's in-app search which
lets you search your entire phone
through all the apps installed you get
doze of course which optimizes apps for
standby and while this is a
pre-production model I do have to
mention the standby time has been
actually amazing seriously impressive
I slept it for like 24 straight hours
with the second screen still on and I
woke it up with 96% left so that kind of
blew my mind still basically a full
battery that's nice you get the new
Vulcan API for gaming performance with
the apps that do support it
you get a direct reply feature though it
is already skinned and you get the
multi-window multitasking although
that's already skin too so believe it or
not you might have noticed this already
you get the choice to have no app drawer
and just have all your icons spread out
across your home screens like it and I
guess like an iPhone but that's not a
requirement of Android and or anything
that's just an option here like pixel
launcher is still a thing don't get
worried but I thought that was pretty
interesting on performance throughout
the whole OS as you can see on the phone
has been pretty solid so let's turn it
into a pretty complete package as far as
Android smartphones go you know the
specs Snapdragon 820 Adreno 530 4 gigs
of ram 64 gigs of storage before you
expand it quick charge 3.0 USB type-c I
mean it's all there it's still very LG
meaning the cameras at the back are
still that LG style with the dual
cameras it still got that second display
up at the top and you can only let LG
choose what can go there when and all
the other things like the skin that's on
top of the software but as of right now
this is still the only phone that you
can get out the box with Android 7.0
nougat and it turns out to be a really
good one so I wouldn't turn you away
from it you should check it out I'll
link it below that's pretty much it
thank you for watching I'll talk to you
guys the next one peace
[Music]